افادت وسائل اعلام تابعه لانصار الله بان
ما وصفته بالعدوان الامريكي والبريطاني
استهدف منطقتي الكثيب والجبانه في
المحافظه محافظه الحديده غربيه البلاد
وكانت وسائل الاعلام ذاتها افادت في وقت
سابق ان قصفا امريكيا وبريطانيا استهدف
بغارتين منطقه راس عيسى في مديريه الصليف
بالمحافظه محافظه
الحديده نذهب الى محافظه الحديده غرب
اليمن معنا من هناك مراسلنا سمير نمري
سمير احطنا باخر عمليات القصف والاستهداف
من قبل الطرفين الامريكي البريطاني وايضا
الحوثي نعم سلمى نحن نشهد خلال الايام
الاخيره وتيره تصاعد وتيره القصف الامريكي
والبريطاني على عدد من المواقع العسكريه
في اليمن قبل قليل اعلت وسائل اعلام تابعه
لانصار الله عن استهداف منطقتي الكثيب
وكذلك الجبانه وهذه المناطق موجوده هنا في
مدينه الحديده وتقع وتقعان بالقرب من
ميناء
الحديده الاستراتيجي والاقتصادي والشريان
الرئيسي لليمن وهذه المناطق تضم معسكرات
قد تم استهدافها تقول انصار الله انها قد
تم استهدافها مرارا وتكرارا وان هذه
الضربات لا تقوم بايه اضرار او لا تنتج
عنها ايه اضرار كان هناك ايضا مساء امس
قصف ايضا على منطقه الصليف وراس عيسى وهذه
ايضا تضم ميناء نفطيا شمالي مدينه الحديده
كذلك ايضا كان هناك قصف امريكي بريطاني
بحسب مواقع انصار الله على منطقه باقم في
محافظه صعده شمالي اليمن هذه الوتيره من
المتصاعده في القصف الامريكي والمكثف خلال
الايام الماضيه استهدف عدد من محافظات
الجمهوريه اليمنيه بما فيها الحديده وكذلك
حجه وايضا صنعاء العاصمه صنعاء وتعز
والبيضاء تقول القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
في كل بياناتها بانها تقوم باستهداف
صواريخ بالستيه وكذلك ايضا طائرات مسيره
وزوارق مسيره كانت معده او جاهزه للاطلاق
نحو سفن الامريكيه والبريطانيه في البحر
الاحمر وخليج عدن كانت اخر عمليه اعلن
عنها الناطق العسكري باسم انصار الله يحيى
سريع يوم الثلاثاء الماضي عندما قال ان ان
قواته استهدفت سفينتين احداهما امريكيه
والاخرى بريطانيه وانهما وانه ان القوات
اصابتها اصابه مباشره شكرا لك كان
قائد قد اعلن يوم امس تاكيده على استمرار
العمليات العسكريه في البحر الاحمر وخليج
شكرا لك من الحديده غربي اليمن مراسلنا
سمير
النمري